one of the scariest words in the
dictionary for most people is the word
change but here's the thing we change
change is absolutely inevitable there's
nothing you and I can do about it it is
coming
you're changing I'm changing but there
are certain people that end up choosing
to change so what causes us to change so
today in this episode I'm going to give
you science behind change in for you to
look at it and say well maybe I want to
change my life as well how do I go about
doing this so let's get right into it
first of all four things cost people to
change you and I number one is
intentional you choose to change it is
intentional I choose to lose weight I
choose to get married I choose to stop
my single habits I choose to smoke stop
smoking pot I choose to do certain
things I'm choosing to change number two
is natural evolution the 40-year old
version of you is going to be a lot
different than a thirty row version of
you then a twenty-year Overson of you
then the ten euro version of you then
the 8000 version of you and that's
natural that's evolution you can evolve
things are going to happen life is going
to happen and you are naturally going to
change none of us are going to be the
same as we are today ten years from now
it's either going to be positive or
negative but there's going to be some
sort of change and the other one is a
life changing event let me tell you what
life changing event is life changing
events sometimes it's accidental what is
accidental for instance I went to this
party and this birthday party I want to
and I was standing on the side and I was
listening to music and all of a sudden I
look to my right I see this girl
standing next to me I could not believe
her eyes and as she looked at me and she
gave me that smile that I'll never
forget and then I smiled back and then I
asked her for her name hello then she
gave me her name I told him she's there
with somebody she said no we started
talking I said you want to leave we left
we went to a restaurant we talked to a
two o'clock in the morning I dropped her
off 18 months later we got married you
know now we've been married for 22 years
and we have three kids together that is
a life-changing event and it was
accidental it wasn't something that was
planned right life change any man could
be you know on the intentional side I
decided to go to this conference
this conference completely changed my
life because I wanted to change my life
here's another life-changing event I
just had a baby it was intentional me
and my wife chose to have a baby me and
my husband chose to have a baby we have
a baby I'm a father I've never cried
like this once I hold a baby I realized
this was my blood or I had a baby but
it's accidental you know hey I wasn't
expecting to get pregnant and have a
baby man I can't believe I'm having a
baby at 19 years old at 18 years old but
it changed my life
accidental intentional intentional or
life-changing a man could be kids
marriage spiritual it could be a lot of
different things then force and by the
way life changing man could also be a it
could be a death in the family it could
be a loss of a loved one death and a
family changes people when your parents
spouse kids sibling somebody a friend we
just had one right now was in Miami did
life this is things happen and it
changes you next one it's pours what's
force you're raising a family and and
then mom and dad get into an accident
there's no more mom and dad you are
forced to change right you're living in
a country all of a sudden there's war
you're under attack you don't have a
choice you are forced to change you're
living in a family market tanks your dad
was doing mortgages you guys go from
living in a million-dollar home you lose
every single thing you're not living in
a one-bedroom apartment complex mom and
dad go through a divorce you're 14 years
old you're forced to change you are
forced to change so change it's coming
to you to me to everybody it's
inevitable we can choose it's going to
be natural some of its going to be
forced some of it's going to be life
changing now having said that let me
come to this site here why do some
people end up changing okay one they're
bored you may be bored with your life
bored with your girlfriend bored with
your boyfriend bored with your job board
with whatever you're doing like I am so
flipping bored with my life that I want
it to all change great that could be a
reason for somebody changes number two
you're inspired I read this book I'm
inspired i watch this movie I'm inspired
write the story I'm inspired I heard
this guy speak I'm inspired to have this
more conversation with this person I'm
inspired I had a dream the other damaged
fire let me tell me I'm going to go to
some significant with my life I saw what
happened with my mom last week I'm
inspired you get inspired number three
is you're frustrated why are you
absolutely frustrated with something
that happened in your life you're
frustrated with your financial situation
relationship your career your job your
health your body your weight it could be
so many different thing but frustration
causes you to change you've heard of
pain and pleasure before by rama's but
I'm giving it to in a complete different
way right now I'm talking boredom
inspiration frustration so now having
said that the part about change that
most people because change is happening
no matter what it's either positive or
negative there's nothing you can do
about that part you are going to change
I am going to change everybody changes
think about in high school I want you to
think about a person that was very happy
to be around 15 years later you see him
the person is the most negative person
to be around they change but that was
negative go back to high school think
about the person that was nobody
negative there just wasn't anybody that
everybody talked about 15 years later
now you just call like what happened to
this guy positive change the key word
positive the key would change you got to
realize it it's two ways people see it
one is an inside job two is an outside
job outside is red you don't control
outside so people who you know tell you
know I can you don't I wish my life I
had a different moment that with money
life would have been different if I
would have married somebody else man if
I had a different fight if I would have
if I lived in a different fight only if
I if I so it's always like it's always
outside I said I said I said that that's
not always internal this you control
this you don't control the more you put
it here the more you're trying to say I
don't have control the more you put it
you the more you're sending up control
so inside job job you can do something
about it people you can do something
about it your friends you can change
your friends family can choose who
you're hanging out with your family
feeding your mind you can choose the TV
shows you're watching the movies you're
watching the music you listen to maybe
you want listen to too much eazy-e you
may be listening to too much who is the
one today that's gangster there's not
really gangsta rap nowadays like they
used to be right
to be easy you had you know who is it -
who's today trick ISM has no gangster
rap um no he's not a gangster up I'm
talking like you're listening to
gangster will you listen to - sure this
will run really too short wow so music
books you listen to write that that can
what are you feeding your mind this you
can choose to control and it is an
inside job and I've learned people that
generally change positively there's two
things they have in common they're
willing to change and they choose to
change if these two are not in place a
person is forced to change by one of
these not by this so if it's intentional
and you're willing and you choose to
change you can change your life into
whatever you want to change your life -
you can't sit there and say you know
what it's never going to happen to me
then you're right it is going to happen
to me you're also right so if you want
to change you can definitely find ways
to change yourself and your life and the
people that do this is the process they
go through to change themselves Paul let
me get my pillow right there we get the
pillow right there buddy
you're thrown okay good throw if you
have not subscribed to this channel yet
click on the subscribe button and the
alert button if you got any questions
thoughts any comments comment on the box
[Music]
you